for many patients at sri lanka's main
cancer hospital the recent economic
crisis has become a matter of life or
death
eighty percent of medical supplies are
imported but there's hardly any foreign
currency to pay for them if you are in a
queue for
fuel ultimately the people will lose the
fuel
if they are the queue for the gas
ultimately they lose the gas
but
if patients are on cue for the drugs
they will lose their life
doctors at the hospital say they've been
forced to suspend tests and postpone
procedures and even critical surgeries
our lives are at risk because of that we
are always living in fear we don't know
whether we will have medicines or not
the hospital is short of injections for
dialysis patients some cancer drugs and
medicines for people who have had organ
transplants
foreign donors including japan and india
are helping but it'll take two to four
months for the drugs to arrive
much of the blame for sri lanka's
economic collapse is being laid at the
feet of president gotta buy rajapaksa
he's on the right here swearing in new
ministers
under his family sri lanka borrowed
heavily to fund a large bureaucracy and
military and vanity construction
projects
elder brother mahinda rajapaksa resigned
as prime minister after nationwide
protests
in his place ranel wickramasinga has
been appointed tasked with forming a
unity government
wikra masinga said that when the
rajapaksa's returned to power in 2019
there were 7.5 billion dollars in
foreign reserves
now
the government says there's nearly
nothing left
bernard smith al jazeera